السلام عليكم انا اشرف ابراهيم وده المخبر
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي في الخمسينات اتولد طفل في
منطقه ميونج دونج في سول عاصمه كوريا
الجنوبيه اسمه دو وون تشانج او دون اختصار
لاسره فقيره معدمه هو في ابتدائي بدا
يشتغل عشان يساعد اسرته في المصاريف كان
اغلب شغله في المقاهي بيوزع القهوه لحد ما
اكتسب خبره كبيره فيها ولما وصل بدايه
العشرينات او يمكن قبلها تزوج واحده اسمها
جين سوك كانت تقريبا في نفس سنه الاحوال
الاقتصاديه في كوريا الجنوبيه في الوقت ده
في السبعينات كانت متدهوره والفرص قليله
ومستوى المعيشه منخفض بسبب الصراع على
السلطه بين المدنيين والجيش فقرر دون وجين
مباشره انهم يهاجروا الى الولايات المتحده
وكانت الخطه انهم يمتلكوا مقهى هناك
ويستغل خبرته اللي اكتسبها في مرحله
الطفوله والمراهقه رغم انهم ما كملوش
تعليمهم ههم الاثنين كان مهم سنويه فقط
وفي سنه
1981 وصلوا للولايات المتحده مفلسين تماما
بيتكلموا انجليزي متكسر ما فيش مكان
يسكنوا فيه فضلا عن انهم ما دخلوش كليه
اصلا بدا دون ثاني يوم على طول يدور على
شغل فبدا يلف على المقاهي وبالفعل عمل
مقابله وثاني يوم الصبح كان شغال في
القهوه كان بياخد 3 دولار في الساعه ولكنه
اكتشف سريعا انه مش هيكون قادر على امتلاك
المقهى الخاص به طول ما هو بياخد المبلغ
الصغير ده هو محتاج يدخر علشان يفتح مشروع
المقهى بتاعه ولكن دخله قليل فقرر يلجا
الى العمل الشاق ويضاعف مجهوده دور على
شغلانه انيه في محطه وقود كانت بتمول
عربيات الاثرياء بالغاز وقبل ما يخلص يومه
الاول في الشغلانه الثانيه كان بدا يشتغل
شغلانه ثالثه وهي تنظيف المكاتب وبالتالي
زاد عدد ساعات شغله من ثمان ساعات ل 19
ساعه يوميا في ثلاث وظائف مختلفه وجين
اتعلمت في البيت مهاره تصفيف الشعر وبدات
تشتغل الاثنين كان عندهم خطه ادخار ومحدد
اهدافهم الماليه بوضوح وشغالين عليها دون
وه شغال في البنزينه كان عينه متعلقه
بعربيات الا الرياء اللي بتدخل تمون
وبالذات العربيات الفارهه من نوع البي ام
دبليو والمرسيدس وكان و هوو بيمون العربيه
وبيدر دش مع الزباين سريعا كان بيساله
بيشتغلوا ايه بدا يلاحظ ان الاثرياء ما
كانوش بيبيعوا القهوه خالص اللي هي
المشروع اصلا اللي هو عايز يعملها امال
الناس دي شغاله في ايه اذا كنت انا اصلا
جاي عشان مشروع المقه اغلبهم كان شغال في
تجاره الملابس ومن اللحظه دي بدات كل حاجه
تتغير فقرر يشتغل في محل لبيع الملابس
وكان حريص انه يفهم كل شيء حرفيه دون كان
بيسمع ويستوعب ويمتص الخبره بسرعه لحد ما
جت لحظه التنفيذ كان في الوقت ده عدى ثلاث
سنين من العمل الشاق جدا بنتكلم عن 19
ساعه شغل في اليوم لحد ما قدر يوفر هو
وجين 11000 دولار وفي سنه
1984 وعلى بعد كم بنايه من شقتهم الصغيره
المكونه من غرفه نوم واحده لقيو متجر لبيع
الملابس بيتباع في حي هايلاند بارك في
مدينه لوس انجلس والبائع مسدق دا يبيعوا
ليهم اول صدمه اخدوها ان المحل ده كان في
اكث من واحد فتحوا قبل كده ملابس وقفل
المنطقه فقيره وما فيش بيع دون وجين
اشتغلوا ليل نهار في المحل اللي كان اسمه
وقتها فاشون 21 واللي غيروه بعد كده لاسمه
الحالق فور ايفر 21 كانوا شغالين على
ملابس الموضه السريعه اللي اسمها فاست
فاشن ودي ملابس رخيصه نسبيا بتوا كب
اتجاهات الموضه بسرعه شديده قدر يميز محله
بسرعه بتوفر الفاست فاشن قبل المنافسين
ورغم انهم ما كملوش تعليم الا انهم كانوا
بيدرسوا نقاط ضعف المنافسين واشتغلوا
عليها وكانوا بيحصلوا على البضائع مباشره
من المصنعين باسعار مخفضه للغايه المبيعات
السنويه للشخص اللي كان بيبيع الملابس
قبلهم في نفس المتجر كانت 3,000 دولار
ولكن ايرادات المحل بعد ما اشتراه دون
وعلى غير المتوقع كانت 700000 دولار ومن
هنا كانت البدايه طبعا اسره زي دي ما
تتوقع منهم ان هم يقفوا عند مجرد المحل ده
ولا تقول احنا كده خلاص نجحنا وحققنا
الحلم بتاعنا اننا ممتلك محل حتى لو كان
ملابس مش اهو فنعيش حياتنا بقى الحقيقه ان
الكلام ده ما حصلش دون وجين كانوا بيدخلوا
الارباح بتاعتهم ويعملوا لها اعاده
استثمار ر انفست بروفيتس واتبعوا احدى
استراتيجيات التوسع الطموحه او النشطه
اجريسيف اكسبانشن ستراتيجي وهي بروسبكت
ستراتيجي او استراتيجيه المنقبين ودي
الفئه الاشرس في الفئات الاربعه في
استراتيجيات التوسع الطموح اللي بتقتع
السوق وداعمه البحث عن فرص جديده للتوسع
وبتتميز بالابداع والمرونه التنظيميه كان
كل ست شهور في متجر لفور ايفر 21 في اول
خمس سنين كان عندهم 11 فرع ومن ساعتها لحد
اللحظه دي وهم لازالوا بيتبعوا
الاستراتيجيه دي لحد ما وصلوا دلوقتي ل
790 متجر منتشرين في حوالي 50 دوله حول
العالم واكثر من 3000 موظف ومبيعات سنويه
بحوالي 3ه ونص مليار دولار وصافي ثروه
للاسره الصغيره دي 3 مليار دولار وكعاده
الاعمال التجاريه اللي بتقوم بها الاسر
الكوريه زي تشيبول مثلا البزنس ما بيخرجش
بره العيله وبتظل هي صاحبه الاداره
والملكيه يمكن لحد الجيل الثالث والرابع
زي ما هنوضح بالتفصيل في حلقات جايه ان
شاء الله هنا برده الامبراطوريه متراميه
الاطراف دي مملوكه بنسبه 100% للاسره
المكونه من اربع افراد دون وجين وبناتهم
الاثنين ليندا وايستر اللي شغالين في
الشركه برض وكان وما زال لهم دور كبير في
التوسع الجامح الامبراطوريه والدهم ليندا
ماسكه قسم التسويق في الشركه وايستر
مسؤوله عن تصميم الرسومات
و جهه المتاجر احنا ليه قلنا القصه
المثيره دي بالتاكيد مش من باب حكاوي
التنميه البشريه وقصص النجاح واتبع شغفك
والكلام اللطيف ده ولكن عشان نتعلم درسين
مهمين جدا وهم من الاسباب الرئيسيه اللي
عملت النقله دي في حياه اسره تشانك وطبعا
مش محتاجين ناكد على البديهيات الرئيسيه
اللي ظهرت في القصه وهي ان النجاح بيحتاج
مجهود وعرق وصبر وانه بيتحقق ببطء شديد مش
في سنه ولا اثنين الحاجه الاولى هي قوه
الادخار وتاثيره لو انت عايز تبدا نشاطك
التجاري وما معكش راس مال فالطريق الامثل
والامن انك تبدا تحوش من دخلك ايا كان انت
بتشتغل ايه او بتكسب ايه او بتقبض كام
سواء كنت موظف في شركه خاصه او حكوميه او
عامل في ورش او صنايعي او شغال في سوبر
ماركت او حتى بتبيع جرجير على رصيف بس
قبلها لازم تظبط البيرسونال بدجت او
الميزانيه الشخصيه او ميزانيه المنزل
وتتحكم فيها عمرك ما هتعرف تتدخر لو اللي
جاي على قد اللي رايح وطبعا هيكون مستحيل
من باب اولى لو نفقاتك اكبر من ايراداتك
لان معنى كده انك مغروس في الديون كل واحد
قدر بظروفه ويقدر يهندل ماليته الشخصيه ده
كده بشكل عام لحد ما نبدا سلسله
البيرسونال فاينانشال مانجمنت او الاداره
الماليه الشخصيه واللي هنفصل فيها كل شيء
قريب ان شاء الله الحاجه الثانيه لو انت
بالفعل عندك نشاط تجاري ناجح فلازم
استراتيجيه التوسع تكون مطروحه قدامك على
الترابيزه طول الوقت المشكله هنا انك حتى
لو كنت راضي وقانع بالايراد بتاع النشاط
التجاري ومش عايز تتحرك فالسوق اللي انت
ما بتتحكم فيه هيجبرك تتحرك هي مساله وقت
بس و هينتهي بيك المطاف اما انك تكبر
وتدافع عن مشروعك ومصالحك وتطور من خدماتك
واما انه يجي لك منافس رزل بيتبع
استراتيجيه المنقبين ولا قدر الله تتفرم
وتقفل النشاط بتاعك فاختر لنفسك في
النهايه لو عجبك الفيديو ما تنساش تعمل
لايك وشير وسبسكرايب للقناه حابب اشكر
شركه اكويتي لرعايه الحلقه وهي شركه دوليه
للوساطه الماليه وتداول العملات والعقود
مقابل الفروقات مقرها الاردن ومرخصه من
قبل هيئه الاوراق الماليه الاردنيه وهيئه
الرقابه الماليه البريطانيه اف سي ايه
مدرجه تحت بورصه دبي للذهب هتلاقوا في
رابط ليهم في وصف الفيديو لو بتتفرج من
اليوتيوب او في اول تعليق لو بتتفرج من
[موسيقى]
الفيسبوك